Ben you're conservative Destiny you're a
liberal can you each describe what key
values underpin your philosophy on
politics and maybe life in the context
of this left right political Spectrum
you want to go first yeah so I think
that we have a huge country full of a
lot of people a lot of individual
talents
capabilities um and I think that the
goal of government broadly speaking
should be to try to ensure that
everybody's able to achieve as much as
possible so on a liberal level that
usually means some people might need a
little bit of a boost when it comes to
things like education um they might need
a little bit of a boost when it comes to
providing certain Necessities like
housing or food or clothing but broadly
speaking I mean I'm still a liberal not
a communist or a socialist I don't
believe in the you know total command
economy total communist takeover of all
of the uh you know economy but I think
that broadly speaking the government
should kind of like kick in and help
people when they need it and that
government can and should be big not
necessarily I notice that when liberals
talk about government or especially
taxes it seems like they talk about it
for taxes sake or big bigness sake so
people talk about taxes sometimes as
like a like a punishment like tax the
rich uh I think taxing the rich is fine
in so far as it funds the programs that
we want to fund but Democrats have a
really big problem demonizing success or
wealth and I don't think that's a bad
thing uh I I don't think it's a bad
thing to be wealthy to be a billionaire
or whatever as long as we're funding
what we need to fund